when you're talking about permanent
physiological changes do you not agree
just from an ethical standpoint that you
might want extremely strong evidence of
the benefits are you aware of how the
quality evidence grading system works
and how it's applied yeah yeah we've
read through it that's why I'm citing
these journals so which Journal says
something different we should have that
debate tell me a journal that has done
systematic reviews that cites different
evidence that cites strong evidence for
benefits of these therapies the
standards of care were developed based
on extensive you're not telling me any
Journal you're not telling me any study
don't say statement of care yeah so um
only one
the standards of care that's the
standards of care that's that's that's
not a journal that's not a study that's
not an organization it's not an
institution you're just saying words
he's saying show me a study that proves
we should be doing this to kids show me
some evidence she keeps saying standards
of care standards of care is is a phrase
as he says it's just words